facts without fear so far over 7,600
ventilators have been distributed now
nationwide it is going to the areas that
need it most the federal government has
also devoted a tremendous amount of
resources to the state of California la
is now facing a crisis of its own as the
city Skid Row has now confirmed their
first case a corona virus this is a huge
potential problem out in California as
officials rightly worrying that that
virus could rip through LA's enormous
homeless population I lived in Southern
California for five years it's very
large population meanwhile with vital
medical equipment running low nationwide
the FBI look at this they seized nearly
200,000 n95 masks five hundred and
ninety eight thousand medical grade
gloves 130,000 surgical masks from
people hoarding the supplies now sadly
small percentage we see the worst in
people this comes as the very first wave
of n95 mask imports from all over the
world is finally reaching the u.s. now
these are the first major shipments
since February and this by the way bring
us the facts that should concern every
America tonight you need to know it to
protect yourself and your family
multiple breaking news reports on many
fronts tonight the very first time we
now see more than a thousand Americans
have lost their lives to this pandemic
in one 24-hour span so far close to
6,000 Americans have passed away from
this virus that includes over 2,000 New
Yorkers and we have to stop imagine how
much worse this would have been if we
didn't have the travel ban ten days
after the first known case in the United
States and the following quarantine and
subsequent travel bans today the
Pentagon confirmed they are looking to
purchase 100,000 body bags the CDC is
now reporting that those infected with
corona virus can spread the illness for
one to three days before showing any
symptoms I was talking about this very
early I have that on hannity comm if you
want to see it and one preliminary study
found that the virus has the potential
to travel through the air
well dr. oz will weigh in on that
tonight and part of our medical
information for your family and another
study found a small group of coronavirus
patients exhibiting neurological
symptoms fallout from the virus is now
delivering a serious blow to the economy
as well predictable still hard to hear
last week's six point six million
Americans file for unemployment all-time
record over the past two weeks more than
ten million Americans have filed for
unemployment not surprising but it's
hard not every industry is struggling
however alcohol sales went up by 50
percent I don't blame any of you now
let's get to the good news tonight some
hope that brings us hope and that is a
lot to cover there in a time of crisis
it is amazing because you see the best
of America which is the overwhelming
majority of Americans shining through
brighter than ever
doctors nurses scientists researchers
medical professionals janitors and
hospitals everyone in the medical field
heroic work they deserve our thanks
tonight and the supplies they so
desperately need to that end we have New
England Patriots owner our friend Robert
Kraft he just used the team plane to
import 1.2 million and 95 masks from
China to the United States Arnold
Schwarzenegger well he deserves to be
congratulated tonight 1 million dollars
in masks and other gear to hospital
workers you know the TV show the masked
singer well and Fox they donated 10,000
surgical masks to New York hospitals
Dolly Parton donated a million dollars
for coronavirus research hawaiian
airlines is offering free flights for
medical workers they want to come help
those hard-hit areas with Cobra 19 my
love original recipe KFC they are giving
away a million pieces of chicken to
their franchisees in the hopes that they
will distribute it to their local
communities Eastern Airlines
Pennsylvania they patriot 'dear lee six
thousand americans who were stranded
abroad i know for a fact that the state
department has been bringing people back
and working around the clock they've
made it happen
congratulations to secretary Pompeo and
his entire team at Brooks Brothers to
the list of US companies shifting
production
to create these desperately needed
medical supplies
they're going to manufacture 150,000
mass per day now what we're seeing is
the best in America here the
overwhelming numbers of people 80 90 %
of Americans doing whatever they can do
they see this unprecedented situation
unfolding they're stepping up
unfortunately there's a lot of jackasses
in the media mob and the psychopaths in
the Democratic Party
yeah more concerned with bludgeoning
President Trump than actually helping in
this moment of crisis in the middle of a
national emergency the medium mob
actively trying to suppress information
that the President of the United States
is giving to the American people one
far-left media group is actually
petitioned the FCC to actually censor
the president's daily coronavirus task
force pressors they don't want Americans
to see the critical information that
they are wanting and needing for their
families and they're not alone either
take a look some of the worst if it were
up to me and it's not I would stop
putting those briefings on live TV but
if he keeps lying like he has been every
day on stuff this important we shouldn't
all of us should stop broadcasting it
honestly it's gonna cost lives
it's obviously above my pay grade I
don't make the call but we take them or
not but it seems crazy to me that
everyone's still taking them when you
got the my pillow guy getting up there
talking about reading the Bible I'm not
actually sure if you want to be honest
that we should carry that live I think
we should run snippets I think we should
do it afterwards and get the pertinent
points to the American people because
he's never ever going to tell you the
truth this week fake news CNN and
Roswell Rachel Maddow so thank God it's
not up to her and of course the
state-run democratic socialist party
MSDN see bowing to pressure from their
conspiracy theorist hosts and frequently
they are cutting away from the President
of the United States while he's given
important information giving that to the
American people during a national
emergency pathetic
despicable but sadly predictable New
York Times encouraging people you should
travel to China on February 5th
oh that's brilliant February 1st mr.
pimple you reading your own newspaper
they're telling their readers at the
Washington Post gotta grip the flu is
you know way worse than the corona virus
according to the Boston Globe Oh
the president has blood on his hands
others bashing yours truly claiming we
have blood on our hands nothing but a
lie we have reported the facts without
fear from day one our very first
interview with dr. pouchy was on January
27th you can see it all on Hannity calm
but of course we know the media mob is
working in conjunction with the
Democratic Party you know they're one in
the same
the same people that have lied for three
and a half straight years yep they're
still at it
and tonight the actions from some top
Democrats is beyond abhorrent here's an
example remember this guy the corrupt
congenital liar compromised Adam Schiff
yeah right now in the middle of a
national emergency we're still
responding he wants the 9/11 Commission
style report on how the president
handled the coronavirus issue
unlike the 9/11 Commission report shifts
political witch-hunt would not
investigate the actions of Congress only
Trump well meanwhile Pelosi has already
set up a committee solely committed to
oversee the president's response to
coronavirus while he was doing the
travel ban let's see you guys were
impeaching him how many Democrats I want
every Democrat answer this question in
retrospect was the president's travel
ban ten days after the first known case
in the US was that the right call in
retrospect she appointed Democratic
majority whip james Clyburn to lead the
committee remember he's the guy who
stated his intention to use the crisis
for quote to restructure things to fit
our vision moments ago the president
responded let's take a look this is not
the time for politics endless partisan
investigations here we go again I've
already done an extraordinary damage to
our country in recent years you see what
happens it's witch hunt after witch hunt
after witch hunt and in the end the
people doing the witch hunt have been
losing and they've been losing by a lot
conducting these partisan investigations
in the middle of a pandemic is a really
big
waste of vital resources time attention
and we want to fight for American lives
not waste time even in the middle of a
national emergency a pandemic Democrats
media mob they can't stop their
compulsion and hatred of Donald Trump
beyond disgusting behavior member I was
saying all the time Donald Trump cured
cancer they'd want to impeach him would
they have enacted the travel ban good
question for anybody running for office
this coming November in 215 days from
today can they even admit that it saved
countless of Americans from contracting
the disease and exponentially
mathematically from dying Pelosi is not
alone in this destructive behavior New
York Senator Chuck Schumer he can't stop
complaining despite the massive amount
of federal assistance it had never been
an effort like this for any one state
the president now directing it all to
New York the epicenter and it's just not
good enough for Schumer in fact he sent
a letter he sent the president a letter
demanding that he appoint a senior
military officer to lead the federal
government's logistical response problem
is Chuck's not paying attention the
president did that a long time ago
take a look Senator Schumer wrote a
letter today and he says you should put
a military manager just it won't suck if
you knew a little bit more we have one
of the most highly respected people in
the military the Admiral this is what he
does to very professionally and he's in
charge but Chuck didn't know that
presidents were doing a travel ban
quarantined and they were Schumer
leading the impeachment also sent a
letter to Schumer writing quote thank
you for your democratic public relations
letter and incorrect sound bites which
are wrong in every way and the president
continued if you spent less time on your
ridiculous and Pietschmann hoax and
instead focused on helping the people in
New York then the state would not have
been so completely unprepared for this
invisible enemy speaking of which today
the President had some strong words for
states like New York this is an epic
fail completely unprepared for any kind
of catastrophe how could that be
take a look the states should have
building fear stockpile we have almost
10,000 in our stockpile and we've been
building and we've been supplying it but
the states should be building we're a
backup we're not an ordering clerk we're
a backup and we've done an unbelievable
job ideally those states should have had
all this equipment and I think they will
the next time you know you heard the
case where thousands of ventilators
could have been had at a very
inexpensive price three years ago and a
certain state decided not to exercise
that right because they wanted to build
a road or they wanted to build something
else because it's big money you're
talking about I think it was a billion
dollars could you talking about a lot of
money for something that may never
happen no it was less than six hundred
thousand but they were spending 750 on a
solar project that went belly-up 90
million and light bulb project belly-up
another 600 million that went belly-up
now that brings us to New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo another constant complainer
and Konrad de Blasio another complainer
tonight we have a comprehensive timeline
detailing how New York's government
failed its citizens in a spectacular
fashion sadly by the way New Yorkers pay
more per taxes per capita than anywhere
else in America let's go way back to
November 2015 the report their president
is referring to the New York State
Department of Health page 30 of that
report during a severe influenza
pandemic there's likely to be a
projected shortfall of ventilators
fifteen thousand seven hundred
eighty-three rounded off to 16,000
during peak week demand after reading
this report Cuomo the governor purchased
zero new ventilators zero not one
instead he instructed the Commission to
figure out ways to ration the existing
2,000 ventilators that's dereliction of
duty especially when he wasted all of
these millions hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars on projects that all
failed but it gets worse flash forward
to this year January 24th Cuomo was
telling his state the coronavirus risk
is is to New York New Yorkers is low
February 6 6 he said the flu is a much
greater risk
March the first he said there's no
reason for undue anxiety the general
risk remains low a few days later well
he said New York can manage the
increasing spread of the virus that's in
March just got out of March he was wrong
over and over again and the worst part
is his state was prepared for nothing
now number one target for terrorism and
if you have a pandemic of any kind New
York highest concentration of people 10
million people in the smallest
geographical area now New York's
healthcare system is so overwhelmed get
this cardiac arrest victims whose hearts
cannot be restarted at the scene they're
not being taken to the hospital as is
usual protocol New York Post broke that
story because of an executive order what
we now know in New York if you want to
take the potentially life-saving
treatment we have talked so much about
hydroxychloroquine you have to go to a
hospital in the state of New York to get
it ah that's a dumb idea
Governor Cuomo this is the only state
now doing this Michigan rescinded it
Nevada rescinded it
rescind the order governor allow New
Yorkers to get the drug if they choose
at a pharmacy and stop pushing people
that don't need to be in a hospital in
to the hospital system now without
Donald Trump's help would have been
overrun by this point and you of course
taking photo ops at all the hospitals at
the president's building for you